it's hot as hell up in this [ __ ] ah I'm
under boots wet touch my touch yours me
okay you wanna know how many times I
pick a lot is work 99 percent failure
rate hey hey what's going on YouTube now
recently a subscriber asked dark
girlfriends are expensive as hell what
do I do about a girl to spend all my
money you know when you're in a
relationship you will find that your
bank account tends to be slim you know
cuz [ __ ] who needs groceries you know
electricity and gas is completely
overrated by the way I just cook my
ramen with a sunlight and a prayer but
you do realize that it's usually like
this right when a relationship begins
you're madly in love you want to impress
it you want to show her a good time and
so when that bill comes out you say hey
[ __ ]
that's my bill you probably don't call a
[ __ ] cuz if you did you'd be
single like me uh-huh and I understand
because at this point in the
relationship you are absolutely head
over heels and your main goal is to find
a way to get inside her pants
everything's cool the beginning you
don't mind spending that money because
you just walk up to her every time you
pick her up in a daisy field and scream
the manager got something you have a
cuddle yo girl and then you slowly enter
towards your penis and then when she
catches on do you blame it on her like
she's nasty just me but but you have to
realize something that the precedents
for her expecting you to pay for
everything was set by none other than I
you because I'm pretty sure from the
get-go you were paying for everything
using stupid-ass lines like my baby
never gonna pay for nothing
Oh real man spend money on his female
yeah you real something real broke [ __ ]
you can't really blame your significant
other for a pattern that you have
complying to and set for yourself think
about it if you were paying for [ __ ]
when you never really had the means to
whose fault is that
you my friend are what we call a
financial [ __ ] you want to be a G so
you act like you had a fat wallet so you
can't really blame her for expecting you
to pay for everything
you lied listen when I been a girl that
I broke I let it up from the get-go all
Oh suck a dick for a sandwich stuff
Danny where'd you get this money to pay
for this meal you [ __ ] you better stop
complaining how to suck a lot of dick
you know you should always be upfront
about you find
situations and if you are impressing a
girl just by buying their [ __ ] and
always using money you don't have to
there are other ways to do things
without spending a lot of guac you have
a build a kite with a girl with your
broken dreams listen if a woman is there
for me from the get-go when I am broke
and poor guess what when I flourish imma
buy that [ __ ] a leprechaun and a pot of
gold and a unicorn to shoot out a spear
to step aside and write in his chest and
take over this water kingdom with the
fun but right now in the beginning
stages I need a down there's [ __ ] that
knows I'm broke coz if we had a bar and
a guy hits on you and offers you a drink
[ __ ] you take it I got it like that no
water girl take you to a nice French
restaurant maybe you heard of it neck
don't now I got it like that and you
know I'm not really saying that guys
that constantly pay for the girls are
stupid in any type of way if you had the
financial means to do that then of
course you should but if the basis of a
woman's affection is based on the
materialistic things that you give her
guess what I say she a gold digger
oh she take my money I want to be with a
woman that will be with me whether I am
rich or poor and preferably has the back
like Queen Latifah I want that girl to
look like a linebacker and beat my penis
like she mad at it
the president's bad I'm gonna blame your
significant Naya whether I am rich or
poor and preferably preferably Presley's
not even a word listen if Oh what the
[ __ ] am I saying but you want to do is
be with the woman that wants to be with
the power